Why you emotional? Why you Someone
should kill you. Someone should cut your
throat open. How about that? And I'll
say you want someone to kill me. I'm not
scared. I'm going to leave you. You
clearly mentally not well. This is very
Jewish. You're You're a Jew. Wah. You're
a Jew. And your blood is your blood. Now
you finished. Correct. Can I ask you
something?
You're finished
now. See
the will have a party if I die cuz they
seem sees that. Alhamdulillah is
spreading. Do you believe I'm Muslim?
No. Okay. Well, how can I become Muslim?
First of all, you need to affirm Kufur.
Yes. You disbelieve in
the the Yahoodi ones.
The bin Salman. Okay. You know, so wait,
did you understand? So Muhammad said man
if I don't believe he's a Muslim that's
the problem brother step by step by step
brother so if I do not believe said
brother if I don't believe if I do not
believe Muhammad Salman is not is not
I'm careful
no no this is what you talking about
this whole no oh my god dude believe in
him I don't
agree would make me different this is
this is whole different not you get
first of all you get I'm using your own
words and guess you can ask why I'm a
Catholic I just have a question what
what what I here to talk about you told
me I have to believe in then you said to
me then you said no brother do you
understand what you're saying do you
listen to yourself do you listen to
yourself I'm saying you're a mer because
you have you haven't you haven't
disbelieved in the of street you
understand that I disbelieve
in But you you h you don't believe in
you you dis you you haven't disbelieve
in the of you how many times I believe
in someone look look if someone says
mash is like Allah is a I believe in him
okay if someone believes in believe in
every yes or no to be a Muslim
wait this is basic Islam you step by
step by step you're lying against me
stop playing for the audience let's just
talk don't play for the audience let's
just talk I'm talking to you guide me
guide me I want you to guide Okay. If
you want me to guide you, can you listen
then? Yeah. Okay. Step back. But listen,
but I just want to talk about AMJ.
I don't you just told me guide me then
he's talking. I'm telling you to guide
me away from him and and show me how the
point is that he's about the idoly. It's
not himself. It's about the idol. Okay.
Listen. Anyway, so I'm not that
knowledgeable. Listen look. I'm going to
say the one I'm Look, I'm going to say
one thing. I'm going to say one thing
and I'll let you speak. I'm not that
knowledgeable. I should I shouldn't even
be debating cuz first of all, the Salv
didn't debate with mess. Number two, you
debate. How about you talk to people who
actually are knowledgeable? But this is
the this is the bad thing about you. You
talk to people who are not
knowledgeable, but you you go ahead.
When people are knowledgeable, you run
from them. This is very Jewish. You're
you're a Jew. Wah. You're a Jew and wah
bless Allah. This is very Jewish. You're
you're a Jew. Wah. You're a Jew. And wah
bless Allah. You clearly
mentioned you clearly
mention being killed way this man he say
people should kill me and you can see
he's mentally not well you can't see
that you know this guy have his head
that's why the they killed my forefather
abal they live my
forefather that's why
alive when they couldn't when they saw
that Islam is spreading. I said to him,
tell me why he
said he's not happy with me is not happy
with that. Then he
said I said if I don't accept is a I'm a
he said no. So I said what are you
talking about
then? You can see how mental they not
well. Subhan Allah. Subhan Allah.